das blut tropft noch von der schwert
klinge der held der ersten staffel ist
tot
geköpft auf befehl des neuen königs
kaum zwei folgen zuvor stand der held
languedoc stark als moralisch aufrechter
sieger da doch er war naiv und nicht
vertraut mit den intrigen am königshof
soll das euer schild sein los da ein
stück papier
ich hatte euch gewarnt wer nicht zu
vertrauen wenn man das spiel der throne
spiels gewinnt man oder stirbt gerät man
in den wirbelsturm der politischen
veränderungen und kämpft um die macht
wird es zum tödlichen spiel
ich weiß nicht
die fernseh serie game of thrones bricht
alle rekorde und läuft in 80 ländern
die romane die als vorlage dienen wurden
in 40 sprachen übersetzt
die serie ist so tief in die
englischsprachige kultur gedrungen dass
sogar die queen dem eisernen thron aus
der serie ihre aufwartung machte
erfinder des epos ist der
us-amerikanische schriftsteller george
rr martin seit seiner romane als tv
serie laufen ist er zum kultautor
avanciert bei seinem besuch am passiere
dem filmfestival nie finisher tel
spricht er über seine faszination für
ritter in der theorie diente dieses
unglaubliche system der ritter dazu die
schwachen zu beschützen
die frauen die kinder und die wehrlosen
zu verteidigen darauf haben sie den eid
geleistet was sie wirklich getan sie
haben geplündert angezündet gestohlen
vergewaltigt und genau aus diesem
gegensatz heraus entsteht enormes drama
auf der einen seite das ideal auf der
anderen die realität
das macht die geschichte aus
in game of thrones bekämpfen sich sieben
königreiche bis aufs blut
der minderjährige könig der könige hält
seine macht durch kaltblütigkeit und im
norden hinter einer 200 kilometer langen
mauer lauert das böse die unbekannten
nutzte vor allem aber sind es
machtspiele und intrigen die die
geschichten vorantreiben
seid ihr ein freund von rätsel wieso
bekomme ich gleich als zu hören
drei große männer sitzen in einem raum
ein könig ein priester und ein reicher
mann
zwischen ihnen steht ein gewöhnlicher
söldner jeder große mann bittet den
söldner die anderen beiden zu töten
wer überlebt wer stirbt das kommt auf
den söldnern tatsächlich er hat weder
krone noch gold noch immer die gunst der
götter hat ein schwert die macht über
leben und tod aber wenn männer mit
schwertern herrschen
warum machen wir uns dann vor dass
könige die macht haben eine interessante
frage wer glaubte söldner hat die macht
hat gott die macht dann folgte dem
priester glaubte das geld beherrscht die
welt dann folgte dem rechen man nimmt
das gold oder gilt die autorität des
staates
dann ist der verpflichteten könig zu
dienen
es sind solche fragen die regelmäßig zum
gemetzel führen angereichert mit
brachialen ritter kämpfen heiße erotik
und einer gehörigen portion fantasy wird
aus der fernsehserie ein weltweiter
blockbuster
george rr martin hat versprochen zwei
weitere romane zu schreiben
seither warten die fans ungeduldig doch
solange er durch die welt tourt sitzt er
nicht am schreibtisch und die fans
wissen der winter naht ein schlüsselsatz
aus dem roman und ohne fortsetzung wird
es sehr sehr dunkel werden